every week we look at stuffs meant for
kids boys and girls are supposed to
enjoy these things we take a long hard
close look at them you say these are
inappropriate toys [ __ ] making loved
this cookie man yeah my god happy sobbed
with a big soft chocolate chip cookie so
it's from missing all week
simon west well sent this in this is
from his kids kindergarten class and
it's just you know in kindergarten when
you get more they call them cubbies the
cubbies the cubby hole right where you
hang up your jacket and put your book
stuff and everything this is from his
kids class he thinks maybe these cubbies
are inappropriate I don't know let's
take a look and see what happens for
kindergarteners that might be a little
advanced unless it's a swingers club
that his kids are enrolled in Liam
Neeson's [ __ ] is so big that's all right
seemed inappropriate this comes from
Kent from Indiana he said a long time
listener first time a mailer I saw this
paw patrol toy set this week you guys
ready with how do you know paw patrol
you have a grown kid I do but I go to
toy stores a lot that seems
inappropriate what are you trolling the
hallways what's going to stay abreast
man I always love toys since I was a kid
so I was like to see what they sell I
don't buy so much anymore now I'm old
enough mature enough to look at it and
be like I'm glad it exists and walking
we'll have to take it home
Jason Musa on the other hand is just Oh
Kevin's walking through the toy stores
again talking to the kids Muse buys
everything now does he [ __ ] yeah I
just saw him last night he was building
a Lego a giant Lego Deathstroke got a
little kid he can get away with it it's
nothing to do with whatsoever kid has
her own toys those you know no paw
patrols a cartoon show on Nickelodeon I
believe it is this is the characters
there's Ryder and the rest of the paw
patrol they're adorable
anyway can't saw this and I'm pretty
sure this is a knockoff this is a
bootleg paw patrol toy I don't think
it's the real deal let's take a look and
I can show you why in the center here it
says
interesting instead of paw patrol hey
that is a way to go but I think it's
down here that is more the indicator
it's the paw patrol concentration camp
is the name of the toy set
I get the sense maybe something was lost
in translation for whoever made that toy
maybe it's like they it's a toy meant to
help you concentrate it's a game of some
kind I don't believe it's the
concentration camp toy you know Ram man
I'm guessing the paw patrol dare take
this into the shower hey I didn't write
history that's true II didn't and
speaking of inappropriate toys this this
one's fan-fucking-tastic this week this
comes from Bjork Petersen from Denmark
the ark I believe is how you say his
name BJ AR ke Peterson from Denmark is a
toy called the feisty pet I don't know
if you guys are familiar with a feisty
pet or not it's a stuffed animal - plush
animal it comes for example this is the
unicorn it's adorable that's the
unicorns the feisty pet when you just
look very feisty eyes are half closed
when you squeeze the back of it this is
what happens first II when you squeeze
the toy its face changes and that
happens now imagine you're a small child
and mom brings home the feisty pet well
actually you don't have to imagine
here's a little video of a mother giving
her son
the feisty pet
[Music]
watch West and luck oh my god is legit
scared that kid was like that's true
terror on his face yes looks like the
[ __ ] Exorcist is coming at him that's
why I feel dirty watching that man like
it was fun first time I feel like oh my
god that kids drop his [ __ ] heart
stopped can we show that again one more
time one more time can we take a look at
that video again kids in therapy for the
rest of his life man
he looks so haunted our new weekly
saying but your mom's a bit of a [ __ ]
[Music]
you
[Music]